WE THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS AND
ELECTIONS WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON, EVERYBODY, AND
WELCOME. WE HAVE ONE MEASURE ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY. WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM. SO WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND THE BILL IS SB
299 FROM SENATOR LIMÓN. SENATOR
LEMON, YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
MEASURE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
SB 209 IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
UPGRADE OUR CURRENT VOTER
REGISTRATION SYSTEM AND HELP
WELCOME ELIGIBLE VOTERS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO 4.6
MILLION ELIGIBLE, BUT
UNREGISTERED VOTERS, A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF WHOM
ARE YOUTH, PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES, BLACK, LATINO,
ASIAN AMERICAN, NATIVE,
INDIGENOUS AND OTHER PEOPLE OF
COLOR, INCLUDING PEOPLE WITH
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY AND
LOW INCOME CITIZENS. THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS LEAVING OUT MILLIONS
OF ELIGIBLE VOTERS EACH YEAR. 1
MILLION ELIGIBLE VOTERS CONDUCT
A LICENSE TRANSACTION AT THE DMV
BUT DO NOT REGISTER TO VOTE. SB
299 HAS TAKEN SUBSTANTIAL
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY. THE
BILL DOES THREE THINGS A IT
REQUIRES THE DMV TO IMPLEMENT A
NONCITIZEN FILTERING SYSTEM. SO
IF A PERSON PROVIDES PROOF OF
NON CITIZENSHIP, SUCH AS A GREEN
CARD, THE APPLICANT WILL
AUTOMATICALLY BE FILTERED OUT OF
OUR VOTER REGISTRATION SYSTEM.
SECOND, THE BILL REQUIRES THE
DMV TO AUTOMATICALLY CHECK VOTER
REGISTRATION STATUS DURING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR ID
TRANSACTION AND TAILOR THE MOTOR
VOTER PROCESS TO WHETHER THE
PERSON IS UNREGISTERED OR
ALREADY REGISTERED TO VOTE IN
CALIFORNIA. LASTLY, THE BILL
GRANTS THE SECRETARY OF STATE
AUTHORITY TO ADOPT REGULATIONS
TO GENERATE A LIST OF PEOPLE FOR
PRE-APPROVAL PRE-APPROVED FOR
REGISTRATION LIST BASED ON
CONFIRMED CITIZENSHIP STATUS
THROUGH THE DMV LICENSE OR
IDENTIFICATION CARD APPLICATION
PROCESS. THIS PRE-APPROVED LIST
WILL BE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS RAISED
ON THE BILL, SB 299 HAS DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO 2030. SB
299 HAS BROAD AND DIVERSE
COALITION OF SUPPORTERS, MANY OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN DOING THE WORK
TO REGISTER THE POPULATION
GROUPS THIS BILL AIMS TO
SUPPORT. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS BILL FOR TWO YEARS. IT IS
SUBSTANTIALLY DIFFERENT FROM
WHERE WE STARTED AND WHILE WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE OPPOSITION, WE
DO HAVE GREAT SUPPORT, WHICH IS
EVIDENT, I THINK, FROM THE FOLKS
WHO ARE HERE. BUT ADDITIONALLY
IT IS WITH THE HOPE THAT WE CAN
FIND A WAY TO REGISTER ELIGIBLE,
BUT THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE
4.6 MILLION ELIGIBLE BUT
UNREGISTERED VOTERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE. WITH ME
TODAY, WE HAVE SIDNEY FONG FROM
ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS FOR CIVIC EMPOWERMENT.
HERE AS WELL AS NEIL O'BRIEN
FROM THE INSTITUTE FOR
RESPONSIVE GOVERNMENT TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. YOU OKAY? THANK
YOU. ARE THOSE YOUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? OKAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME FORWARD?
AND YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES.
WHO ARE THEY? WHAT ARE THE NAMES?
OKAY. WHO ELSE? WHAT ABOUT. OKAY
HELLO, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS SIDNEY FONG, AND I'M THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR ASIAN
AMERICANS. AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
FOR CIVIC EMPOWERMENT. I'M ALSO
PROUDLY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA GRASSROOTS DEMOCRACY
COALITION, WHICH COMPRISES OVER
140 ORGANIZATIONS THAT ENGAGE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
WORKING CLASS AND VOTERS OF
COLOR. YEAR ROUND. SENATOR LIMÓN
AND OUR COALITION HAVE BEEN
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING CONCERNS
FROM ALL PARTIES, AND THE
CURRENT VERSION OF SB 299
REFLECTS THAT COMMITMENT. THIS
MEASURE REMOVES BARRIERS TO
VOTING WHILE PROTECTING
NON-CITIZENS AND IMPROVING THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR VOTING SYSTEM.
HISTORICALLY, VOTER REGISTRATION
WAS DESIGNED AND IMPLEMENTED TO
KEEP MINORITIES AND POOR
COMMUNITIES FROM VOTING. THE
IMPACTS OF THIS RACIST LEGACY
PERSISTS TODAY AS CALIFORNIA'S
4.6 MILLION UNREGISTERED
ELIGIBLE CITIZENS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK,
LATINX, AND ASIAN AMERICAN. BY
STREAMLINING REGISTRATION FOR
ELIGIBLE BUT UNREGISTERED
PEOPLE, CALIFORNIA CAN REMOVE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
REGISTRATION FOR MILLIONS OF
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE, PEOPLE OF
COLOR, AND YOUNG PEOPLE. SB 209
ALLOWS THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
LAUNCH A PREAPPROVED
REGISTRATION LIST WHEN THE STATE
IS EQUIPPED WITH THE FUNDING AND
TECHNOLOGY. THIS UPDATE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT FOR ORGANIZERS LIKE
MYSELF, WHO WILL BE POUNDING THE
PAVEMENT DAY IN AND DAY OUT,
MOBILIZING VOTERS TO GET FOLKS
TO THE POLLS RATHER THAN
CONVINCING THEM TO REGISTER. SB
209 WOULD PROVIDE VITAL
PROTECTIONS FOR NON-CITIZENS.
FROM OUR WORK ACROSS THE STATE,
WE HAVE ENCOUNTERED NON-CITIZEN
RESIDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
MISTAKENLY REGISTERED TO VOTE
THROUGH THE CURRENT AVR SYSTEM
WITH SB 299 LICENSE, APPLICANTS
WILL BE AUTOMATICALLY FILTERED
OUT OF MOTOR VOTER IF THEY
PROVIDE A GREEN CARD OR OTHER
DOCUMENTS CLEARLY INDICATING
NON-CITIZENSHIP AS A PART OF
THEIR TRANSACTION. THIS
STRAIGHTFORWARD CHANGE PREVENTS
NON-CITIZENS FROM MAKING AN
HONEST MISTAKE DUE TO
INATTENTION, CONFUSION, OR
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY.
YOUR SUPPORT IS CRUCIAL TO
ENSURING THAT ALL ELIGIBLE
CITIZENS CAN EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR BACKGROUND. FOR THESE
REASONS, I STRONGLY AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR SB 299. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND BEFORE WE GO TO
THE SECOND WITNESS, LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SO WE'LL ASK
THE ASSISTANT TO CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BLAKE SPEER, PRESENT
SHAKESPEARE, PRESENT. ONE HERE,
ONE HERE. ALAN ALLEN HERE.
MENGIBAR NEWMAN. HERE. NEWMAN
HERE. PORTANTINO. UMBERG OKAY.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM. SO NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OUR SECOND LEAD WITNESS. THANK
YOU FOR COMING, CHAIR BLAKE. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. MY NAME IS NEIL
O'BRIEN. I'M THE POLICY AND
RESEARCH DIRECTOR AT THE
INSTITUTE FOR RESPONSIVE
GOVERNMENT ACTION, A NONPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
IMPROVE GOVERNMENT ACCESSIBILITY
AND EFFICIENCY. I'M HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB 209, WHICH
IS A MODIFIED VERSION OF SB 846,
WHICH PASSED THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR. SB 299, LIKE SB 846, MAKES
CALIFORNIA'S VOTER REGISTRATION
PROCESS MORE SECURE, EFFICIENT
AND ACCESSIBLE, ACCORDING TO
SECRETARY OF STATE DATA.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO 4.7
MILLION ELIGIBLE UNREGISTERED
PEOPLE, 1 IN 6 ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS IS NOT REGISTERED
TO VOTE, A POPULATION THAT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY YOUNG PEOPLE
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. MOST OF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE BEING LEFT OUT
BY THE CURRENT MOTOR VOTER
SYSTEM, WHICH REQUIRES CUSTOMERS
TO OPT IN TO VOTER REGISTRATION.
SECRETARY OF STATE DATA
INDICATES THAT EACH YEAR, 1
MILLION ELIGIBLE UNREGISTERED
PEOPLE CONDUCT A LICENSE
TRANSACTION AT THE DMV BUT DO
NOT REGISTER TO VOTE. SB 299
GIVES THE SECRETARY OF STATE A
POWERFUL TOOL TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM IF AND ONLY IF THERE IS
ADEQUATE TECHNOLOGY AND FUNDING
IN PLACE. THE SECRETARY HAS
DISCRETION TO CREATE A LIST OF
PEOPLE PRE-APPROVED FOR VOTER
REGISTRATION AS A SUPPLEMENT TO
THE CURRENT MOTOR VOTER PROCESS.
THE DMV WOULD TRANSMIT
INFORMATION TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE FOR AN ADDITIONAL GROUP OF
PEOPLE. DMV CUSTOMERS WHO DO NOT
AFFIRMATIVELY REGISTER TO VOTE,
BUT WHO HAVE PROVIDED A U.S.
PASSPORT OR ANOTHER DOCUMENT
CONCLUSIVELY SHOWING U.S.
CITIZENSHIP AS PART OF THEIR
LICENSE TRANSACTION. THESE
CONFIRMED U.S. CITIZENS WILL NOT
BE REGISTERED TO VOTE, BUT THEY
WILL BE PRE-APPROVED FOR
REGISTRATION AND THE SECRETARY
CAN OFFER THEM STREAMLINED WAYS
TO ACTIVATE THEIR PRE-APPROVED
REGISTRATION. THIS PROCESS WOULD
SAVE PEOPLE SUBSTANTIAL TIME AND
EFFORT OF RESUPPLYING ALL OF THE
INFORMATION ALREADY PROVIDED
DURING A DMV TRANSACTION, MAKING
REGISTRATION AND VOTING
SIGNIFICANTLY EASIER. THIS SAME
PROCESS, WHERE THE DMV TRANSMITS
INFORMATION TO ELECTION
OFFICIALS FOR PEOPLE WHO PROVIDE
SPECIFIED DOCUMENTS DURING THEIR
LICENSE TRANSACTION, HAS BEEN
ADOPTED BY TEN OTHER STATES IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. THIS BILL GIVES
THE SECRETARY DISCRETION TO USE
THE SAME PROCESS. SB 299 ALSO
CONTAINS TWO OTHER IMPORTANT
UPGRADES TO THE CURRENT MOTOR
VOTER PROCESS. FIRST, PEOPLE WHO
PROVIDE A GREEN CARD OR OTHER
DOCUMENT CONCLUSIVELY
ESTABLISHING NON-CITIZENSHIP
DURING THEIR DMV TRANSACTION
WILL BE AUTOMATICALLY FILTERED
OUT OF THE CURRENT MOTOR VOTER
PROCESS. THIS SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCES THE RISK OF A MISTAKEN
REGISTRATION BY A NON-CITIZEN,
AND REMOVES A TRAP FOR THE
UNWARY IN THE CURRENT PROCESS.
SECOND, SB 299 REQUIRES THE DMV
TO WORK WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO AUTOMATICALLY CHECK
VOTER REGISTRATION STATUS DURING
A LICENSE TRANSACTION. THIS
ALLOWS THE MOTOR VOTER QUESTIONS
TO BE TAILORED DEPENDING ON
WHETHER THE CUSTOMER IS
UNREGISTERED OR ALREADY
REGISTERED TO VOTE. I'VE
PERSONALLY WORKED ON DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF AUTOMATIC
VOTER REGISTRATION IN 19 STATES
AND WASHINGTON, D.C, AND I'VE
SEEN FIRSTHAND THE FEATURES THAT
MAKE REGISTRATION SYSTEMS
MAXIMALLY ACCESSIBLE, EFFICIENT,
AND PROTECTIVE OF NON-CITIZENS.
THIS BILL INCORPORATES IMPORTANT
FEATURES TO MAKE CALIFORNIA'S
MOTOR VOTER SYSTEM MORE SECURE,
EFFICIENT, AND ACCESSIBLE. I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES, AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO BOTH OF
THE LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE WHO IS A LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION? SORRY.
FIRST WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OTHER
SUPPORT. DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. YES, RIGHT THERE IS
PERFECT. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DAHLIA KING.
I'M WITH CATALYST CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO WE'RE
PART OF A COALITION CALLED THE
ALLIANCE FOR REPARATIONS
RECONCILIATION TRUTH. ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. SARAH BRENNAN
WITH THE WIDEMAN GROUP ON BEHALF
OF NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION? ANYBODY
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPINIONS
OTHERWISE AT THE MICROPHONE,
SOMEBODY DO WE HAVE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE HERE?
WELCOME THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, TIM CROMARTIE, ON
BEHALF OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE. WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR, WITH WHOM
WE ARE COLLABORATING ON A NUMBER
OF OTHER ISSUES, WE DO NOT.
AFTER WEEKS OF NEGOTIATIONS, WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THIS BILL CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED AS WRITTEN. THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF OPERATIONAL
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS THAT
HAVE YET TO BE ADDRESSED WITH
ANY SPECIFICITY FOR EXAMPLE,
DETERMINATIONS OF CITIZENSHIP
STATUS, SCREENING OUT
NON-CITIZENS AND PROTECTING
THEIR DATA FROM MISUSE TO THE
DEGREE THEY NEED TO BE EXCLUDED
FROM FOLKS WHO WILL BE, SLATED
TO REGISTER TO VOTE. WE ALSO ARE
AWARE, IN THE COURSE OF OUR
NEGOTIATIONS THAT A NUMBER OF
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE
YET TO BE PRECISELY DEFINED HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED. THEY ARE GOING
TO BE EXPENSIVE. WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT PLATFORMS THEY WILL BE
SPECIFICALLY. WE DON'T KNOW
PRECISELY WHAT FORM THEY WILL
TAKE. THERE'S A LOT THAT HAS YET
TO BE DETERMINED, AND FOR THAT
REASON, THE BILL HAS HIDDEN
COSTS AND WE HAVE SERIOUS
RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE ABILITY
OF DMV AND SSOS TO JOINTLY
IMPLEMENT IT. NOTWITHSTANDING
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED IN THE BILL BROAD
DISCRETION TO CRAFT IMPLEMENTING
REGULATIONS, SOME OF THE ISSUES
ARE DEEPER THAN THAT. IT'S NOT
THAT WE CAN SIMPLY FIX IT BY
CRAFTING REGULATION FOR EXAMPLE,
IF YOU HAVE A AN INDIVIDUAL, THE
NATIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION ACT,
FOR EXAMPLE, REQUIRES FOLKS WHEN
ACTIVATING THEIR REGISTRATION TO
SELF-ATTEST TO THEIR CITIZENSHIP
STATUS. EVERYONE WHO WALKS INTO
THE DMV IS NOT GOING TO HAVE
PROPER DOCUMENTATION. VERY
OFTEN, PEOPLE MAY BE INTIMIDATED
TO BRING THAT KIND OF THING TO
DMV. THEY'RE NOT IN A FORMAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICE, AND SO THE
SELF-ATTESTATION REQUIREMENT,
WHICH IS REQUIRED BY THE
NATIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION ACT,
IT'S NOT REQUIRED IN THE BILL
CURRENTLY. AND IF THERE'S GOING
TO BE AN ALTERNATE MECHANISM,
IT'S GOING TO BE A TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTION. MOST LIKELY. AND
THERE'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE AN
ANALYSIS AS TO WHETHER THAT
SOLUTION AND ALTERNATE SOLUTION
VIOLATES THAT THE FEDERAL ACT.
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
COMPLICATED, COMPLEX ISSUES THAT
REMAIN TO BE RESOLVED. WE HAVE
SERIOUS RESERVATIONS. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OR OTHER COMMENTS?
NOT SEEING ANY. WE WILL COME
BACK TO THE MEMBERS. SENATOR
NEWMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT? QUESTION? I GUESS
COMMENT, BUT THANK YOU. SO I
ACTUALLY CARRIED A BILL THAT WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO THIS
BILL, I THINK THREE YEARS AGO.
AND I GIVE BOTH THE AUTHOR AND
THE SUPPORTERS CREDIT FOR
WORKING THROUGH VERY
DELIBERATELY, VERY RIGOROUSLY,
THROUGH THE ISSUES THAT
PRESENTED THEMSELVES DURING THAT
CYCLE. AND I THINK, AS NOTED,
YOU KNOW, 1 IN 6 ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS STILL NOT VOTING IS
A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER. AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU CONSIDER WHO
THOSE VOTERS ARE. AND SO I AM IN
SUPPORT OF EFFORTS TO
THOUGHTFULLY, DELIBERATELY AND
WITHOUT, YOU KNOW, JEOPARDIZING,
YOU KNOW, THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS OR CAUSING OTHER PROBLEMS
IS BRINGING THEM INTO THE
SYSTEM. AND I THINK, I THINK I
GIVE THE AUTHOR IMMENSE CREDIT
FOR WORKING ON THIS BILL OVER,
YOU KNOW, VERY, VERY LONG
PERIOD. THERE ARE STILL
CONCERNS, BUT I DO THINK THAT
THEY HAVE ADDRESSED MANY OF THEM,
ONE DELIBERATELY FILTERING OUT
THOSE WHO MIGHT NOT BE ELIGIBLE.
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, THE
PROVISION FOR A PROACTIVE CHECK.
AND THAT HAS TO THEN REACH A
STANDARD THAT IS EQUIVALENT TO
THE SELF-ATTESTATION REQUIREMENT.
BUT I DO THINK IT'S HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND THIS IS
A WORTHY EFFORT. AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WILL SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR NGUYEN. THANK THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. JUST JUST A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS AND I THINK
IT'S KNOWN THAT WE'RE ALL VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF WANTING EVERYBODY
TO REGISTER, WANTING EVERYBODY
TO, I MEAN, VOTER TURNOUT, BUT I
DON'T THINK THE DMV IS WHERE THE
VOTER TURNOUT GOES INTO PLAY. I
DON'T THINK PUTTING REGISTERING
TO VOTE THROUGH THE DMV IS NOT
GOING TO TURN OUT FOLKS TO VOTE.
BUT MY MAIN, MY ACTUAL CONCERN
IS THAT I THINK THE DMV NEEDS TO
STICK TO JUST THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND VOTER AND VEHICLE
REGISTRATION. THAT'S IN ITSELF
IS A REALLY BIG ANIMAL AND LOTS
OF CONCERNS. A LOT OF OUR
CASEWORK COMES TO OUR OFFICE. IS
DMV PROBLEMS. I DON'T THINK, YOU
KNOW, REGISTRATION SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY OF THE DMV. IT SHOULD
STAY WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. IT SHOULD STAY WITH THE
ROV, AND SO I JUST THINK, YOU
KNOW, AS WE KEEP ON PILING INTO
THE DMV, I THINK IT MAKES IT
MORE AND MORE DIFFICULT. AND
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET MORE
ERRORS. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR ALLEN, YOU
KNOW, I'M, I, I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE THEORY OF THE
CASE. I HAVE TREMENDOUS RESPECT
FOR THE AUTHOR, I THINK THAT WE
ALL KNOW THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES HERE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY, I ANTICIPATE
THIS BILL HAVING PROBLEMS, YOU
KNOW, FOR SOME OF THE REASONS
THAT WERE EXPRESSED AT THE
MICROPHONE JUST NOW, AND I THINK
EVEN IF YOU LOOK AT THE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, IT'S
NOT A GOOD LIST TO BE GOING INTO
THE FINAL WEEK WITH OPPOSITION
FROM ON A BILL THAT'S PURPORTING
TO HELP ADDRESS ACCESS ISSUES.
SO, LET'S SEE WHERE THIS GOES.
I, YOU KNOW, I'M SURE WE'LL BE
BACK NEXT YEAR WORKING ON SOME
OF THESE ISSUES, SO BUT AS A
COURTESY TO MY FRIEND, I'LL
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS? NOT SEEING ANY, I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR IF
SHE'D LIKE TO CLOSE. SURE THANK
YOU. AND SO I DO WANT TO COMMENT
ON A FEW THINGS THAT I THINK ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT. ONE, THIS BILL
ALLOWS FOR A PROCESS. SO SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT ARE EXPRESSED
BOTH IN THE LETTER AND IN THE
COMMENTS WOULD BE WORKED OUT
THROUGH A REGULATION. YOU KNOW,
A REGULATION PROCESS THAT WE ARE
NOT DICTATING. SO THAT IS A
PROCESS THAT WILL BE THERE AND
THESE EXACT ISSUES NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT. WE'RE THE FIRST TO
TELL YOU THEY NEED TO BE WORKED
OUT. WE ALSO THINK THAT THEY
NEED TO BE DONE THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WOULD HAVE
DISCRETION. THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO SAY,
HEY, AFTER GOING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS, LOOKING AT SOME OF
THESE ISSUES, YEAH, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD OR NO, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD. SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
REASON THAT WE FEEL STRONGLY
ABOUT THIS BILL IS BECAUSE IT
SETS THE GOALS UP, AND IT MAKES
IT CLEAR WHO HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO SAY WHETHER OR NOT THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD. THIS BILL ALSO
ISN'T GOING TO MOVE FORWARD IN A
SHORT TIMELINE. IT HAS UNTIL
2030, TO BE IMPLEMENTED. I THINK
THE ISSUES WITH THE DMV, WE ALL
HAVE MANY ISSUES WITH THE DMV,
AND I WILL SAY THAT THIS BILL IS
NEITHER GOING TO, YOU KNOW, IT'S
NOT GOING TO SOLVE THOSE. THE
DMV ALREADY IS PART OF
REGISTERING FOLKS TO VOTE
INDEPENDENT OF THIS BILL. AND
LASTLY, THIS IS ALSO RIGHT BASED
UPON APPROPRIATION IN THE FUTURE
BETWEEN NOW AND 2030. SO WHAT
THIS DOES, AND I THINK THAT THIS
PIECE IS THIS IS ONE OF THE
PIECES THAT'S MOST MOTIVATED ME
TO REALLY WORK ON THIS ISSUE IS
IT CREATES A FRAMEWORK AND IT
GIVES TIME FOR US TO MEET IT IN
THIS LEGISLATURE. I HAVE HEARD
TIME AND TIME AGAIN, WELL, THIS
ISN'T THE RIGHT YEAR FOR US TO
DO IT. WE CAN'T DO IT THIS WAY.
WE HAVEN'T SOLVED FOR THIS
PROBLEM. IF WE NOW TELL A STATE
AGENCY AND WE WORK WITH THE
PERSON WHO HEADS UP OUR
REGISTRATION AND VOTING SYSTEM
PROCESS, WHICH IS OUR SECRETARY
OF STATE, AND SAY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE FOR THIS
TO BE ACCOMPLISHED. IT GIVES
THESE BODIES AMPLE TIME TO BE
ABLE TO FIGURE IT OUT. ABSENT
THIS, I CAN GUARANTEE YOU WE'RE
GOING TO BE HERE YEAR AFTER YEAR
ASKING FOR THE SAME OUTCOME, BUT
SAYING, WELL, IT'S STILL NOT THE
YEAR. WE STILL DON'T HAVE MONEY,
WE STILL HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT THE
TECHNOLOGY. AND SO THAT IS ONE
OF THE PIECES THAT HAS MOTIVATED
ME TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS
BILL, DESPITE THE FACT THAT FOR
TWO YEARS IT HAS HAD CHALLENGES
AND I AM CONCERNED THAT NOT
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD, WHAT
IT WILL DO IS WE WILL BE BACK
POTENTIALLY AGAIN NEXT YEAR WITH
THE SAME CONCERNS, THE SAME
OPPOSITION, THAT FOR TWO YEARS
HASN'T WANTED TO GIVE, YOU KNOW,
MORE TO HELP US MAKE THIS BILL
BETTER. AND SO I THINK THAT THIS
IS THE ONLY WAY WE GET FOLKS AT
THE TABLE. AND IT IS REALLY THE
VOICE OF, OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD. SO WITH THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? SO MOVED OKAY.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION
WHICH IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN. SO
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BLAKE SPEAR. AYE. AYE.
WHEN NO. WHEN. NO. ALLEN ALLEN.
AYE. MENGIBAR. NEWMAN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. PORTANTINO UMBERG.
UMBERG. AYE THANK YOU. WE WILL
LEAVE THIS ON CALL. WE WILL GO
INTO A RECESS NOW UNTIL MORE
MEMBERS COME.
OKAY. THANKS SENATE ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS IS
BACK FROM RECESS, AND WE ARE
LIFTING THE CALL. LIFTING CALL
ON ITEM ONE, SB 299. MOTION IS
THE THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
BE CONCURRED IN. CURRENT VOTE IS
FOR ONE CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTED NO. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. PORTANTINO. THANK
YOU. IT IS FIVE ONE AND WE ARE
CLOSING THE ROLL. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY, PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS,
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS IS NOW ADJOURNED.